bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission que certains dirigeants ferait
bien de regarder ça leur apprendrait
peut-être raconté
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches la
rentrée 2021 synonyme de la fin du
fameux quoi qu'il en coûte place
désormais au sur mesure pour les
entreprises annonce faite par le
ministre de l'économie le 30 août
dernier est des annonces qui
interviennent alors que le pass sonitel
est désormais obligatoire pour les 1,8
million de salariés au contact de public
alors à combien s'élève la facture du
quoi qu'il en coûte comment va se mettre
en place le sur mesure pour répondre à
ces questions nous serons en deuxième
partie avec le directeur de l'institut
rousseau nicolas dufresne je vous le
disais bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie s'est exprimé le 30 août
dernier après avoir reçu les
représentants des secteurs toujours
affecté par la crise sanitaire
retour sur ces annonces avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est fini il
difficile de faire plus clair que cette
déclaration de bruno le maire pour
annoncer la fin des aides aux
entreprises pour faire face à la crise
du coc vide selon lui l'économie est
repartie et pour appuyer son annonce le
ministre de l'économie a sorti des
chiffres une croissance prévue à 6 % en
2021 un chômage revenu à son niveau
d'avant crise des demandes de prêts
garantis par l'état divisé par dix en
deux mois entre mai et juillet et des
paiements par carte bancaire durant les
deuxième et troisième semaine du mois
d'août plus importante qu'à la même
période en 2020 le pass and terre
n'aurait aucun impact sur l'économie
d'après bruno le maire
termine à dos les aides en masse il faut
dire que la facture totale de ce fameux
quoi qu'il en coûte et bien ça les 240
milliards d'euros alors attention on ne
coupe pas non plus les robinets d'un
seul coup ce serait un peu raide le
fonds de solidarité est maintenue
pendant septembre à 20% du chiffre
d'affaires et à condition d'avoir un peu
bosser pour réaliser 15% de son chiffre
d'affaires sur semois et d'autres
dispositifs prendront le relais au delà
de septembre mais pour les entreprises
du secteur touristique enfin en
outre-mer les aides continueront tant
que la situation sanitaire ne se sera
pas améliorée pour bercy badauds doute
l'économie est repartie et la crise du
coc vide et déjà un mauvais souvenir
[Musique]
olivier à 18 mois après l'allocution
d'emmanuel à maquereau annonçant que
l'état allait quoi qu'il en coûte
protéger les salariés et les entreprises
bruno le maire a donc fermé le robinet
le 30 août dernier avec à la clé une
facture de 240 milliards d'euros c'est
le bon moment cette rentrée 2011 2021
pour justement fermer le robinet ou
alors est-ce prématurée on essaie
surtout c'est surtout une déclaration
c'est de la com c'est à dire que il vous
dit qu'il va fermer le robinet mais pas
tout à fait parce qu'il va continuer à
faire des aides ciblées et c'est donc en
fait si vous voulez c'est comme
d'habitude il ya il ya une déclaration
et puis il ya ce qu'il ya derrière
malheureusement ils savent très bien que
s'ils arrêtent
vous allez avoir enfin on va pouvoir
faire les comptes si vous voulez c'est à
dire qu'on va
s'apercevoir que beaucoup de chômeurs
partiels on se transformer en chômeurs
tout court et beaucoup de boîtes qui
avait été maintenu en vie totalement
artificiellement vont tomber donc ils le
savent et est donc que vous verrez
qu'ils y reviendra sur ses déclarations
dans peu de temps
malheureusement c'est un système qui met
qui étaient déjà là avant si vous voulez
avant le vide et c'est bien là le
problème c'est à dire que on se vante
d'être revenu à une situation 2019 il
faut voir ce que c'était que la
situation 2019 on était on n'était pas
du tout dans une situation assainie dans
une situation de forte croissance ou
quoi que ce soit donc on revient sur
quelque chose qui est encore là il ya
aussi des doutes parce que la
déclaration comme quoi on va faire 6% de
croissance
quand on voit les chiffres de juillet et
quand on discute un peu quand on sort un
peu de son bureau eh bien on s'aperçoit
que les restaurants vous disent qu'ils
marchent à 30 % de ce que de ce qui se
faisait avant donc
on est loin du compte et je pense que
malheureusement on va s'en apercevoir à
la rentrée plus ils vont sélectionner et
c'est ce qui aurait dû être fait avant
si vous voulez la sélection c'est pas
maintenant qu'il faut la faire c'est pas
une fois qu'on a dépensé des milliards
des centaines de milliards à arroser
tout le monde et à faire tenir des gens
qui n'auraient jamais dû tenir que
maintenant on va pouvoir se vanter de
faire un peu de sur mesure c'est
pathétique c'était c'était dès le départ
qu'il fallait faire du sur mesure mais
ça évidemment il en était bien incapable
donc voilà on a on a aujourd'hui en plus
rappelez vous que dans à peine huit mois
vous avez des élections donc
je doute que il laisse tomber
l'économie qui s'écrasera si elle n'a
pas de de schull si elle n'a pas ses
aides permanente on a remplacé je
voulais dit plusieurs fois ici du
chiffre d'affaires par de la bête mais
c'est une aberration mais je pense
malheureusement qu'on va être obligé de
continuer merci olivier tout de suite la
deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec le directeur de l'institut rousseau
bonjour à nicolas dufresne merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et bienvenue financer cash
bonjour à vous merci de votre invitation
la première question à nicolas dufresne
à partir du moment où l'économie
française tourne à 99 % de ses capacités
nous devons sortir du quoi qu'il en
coûte a expliqué le ministre de
l'économie alors malgré ce fait
constater à part bersier est aujourd'hui
risque est selon vous de sortir de ce
quoi qu'il en coûte
oui alors en effet le quoi qu'il en
coûte déjà il faut savoir ce que c'est
donc bruno le maire l'a rappelé ses 240
milliards d'euros donc il ya eu 80
milliards d'euros de subventions qui ont
servi à financer notamment chômage
partiel et le fonds de solidarité
essentiellement et le reste c'est 160
milliards d'euros de prêts garantis par
l'état ces prêts garantis par l'état il
va falloir les rembourser en tout cas
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'espère le
gouvernement et c'est là que les choses
vont devenir difficiles puisque les
entreprises se retrouvent aujourd'hui
avec un niveau de dette considérable qui
va leur falloir amortir sans pour autant
renoncer à leurs investissements
productifs notamment on a vu que la
l'investissement repart un petit peu à
la hausse mais il faudrait pas casser
cette dynamique et donc toute la
question c'est ne pas refaire
aujourd'hui l'erreur de 2011 qui avait
été de d'enlever les mesures de soutien
à l'économie après la crise de 2008
beaucoup trop tôt ce qui avait cassé
la dynamique économique de la reprise et
ça serait vraiment l'erreur à ne pas
faire aujourd'hui d'autant moins que les
grands pays comme les etats-unis mais
aussi le japon la chine met en place des
plans de relance gigantesque et donc
c'est cette question qu'on peut se poser
c'est est ce que nous sommes vraiment
aujourd'hui au niveau pour accompagner
la reprise
moi je pense pas je pense que d'une part
certaines mesures auraient peut-être pu
être un peu plus prolongé puisque par
exemple le
le fait que le fonds de solidarité doit
être remplacée par une prime par une
aide pardon aux coûts fixes mais
seulement pour les entreprises ou
systèmes logiques oui pardon on
détaillera le sur mesure le sur mesure
dans quelques instants faux c'est seul
arrêt trop brutal selon vous c'est trop
tôt encore je pense que le fonds de
solidarité
oui je pense qu'il faut faire très
attention alors effectivement il y a
beaucoup moins de demandes à la fois
pour le chômage partiel pour le fonds de
solidarité
donc est-ce qu'il était nécessaire de
les resserrer dès maintenant est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu attendre que ces
demandes s'épuise
d'elle-même bon jeu j'ai pas j'ai pas la
réponse il n'est pas anormal si vous
voulez qu au moment où l'économie repart
on puisse commencer à resserrer
les dispositifs mai
d'une part il se resserrait de même donc
là il y avait une volonté je crois que
la part de bruno le maire et c'est ce
qui a été dit aussi par geoffroy roux de
bézieux à l'université du medef que je
le cite le président du medef qui disait
que l'état devait retourner à sa juste
place bon donc sa juste place et ce
serait une folie une place où l'état
n'investit pas beaucoup et ne se mêle
pas de l'économie et d'un autre côté
bruno le maire vient de rendre à la
commission européenne son programme de
stabilité le programme de stabilité de
la france jusqu'en 2027 où il prévoit de
repasser que le déficit de l'état qui
aujourd'hui de 10 % devra repasser sous
la barre des 3% donc ça si vous regardez
les choses toutes choses égales par
ailleurs ça veut dire 15 à 20 milliards
d'euros de réduction de dépenses
publiques chaque année
moi c'est plutôt ça qui m'inquiète si
vous voulez je j'ai peur que on ne casse
la reprise et que l'état n'engagent pas
la véritable politique de reconstruction
écologique ne s'engage pas dans des
grands plans de relance comme il devra
le faire pour que
l'économie continue d'être d'être
dynamique j'ai peur si vous voulez pour
résumer qu'il manque un volet
d'entraînement pour l'ensemble de
l'économie dans cette sortie de crise
du duc au vide olivier vous êtes
d'accord avec ces craintes a évoqué par
nicolas dufresne non enfin moi je pense
que si vous voulez la déclaration de
bruno le maire au medef
c'est une déclaration qui
qui vise un
rassurer les détenteurs de la dette
française
donc c'est vers l'extérieur si vous
voulez c'est pas du tout vers
l'intérieur à ce niveau là et puis la
deuxième chose c'est aussi
rassuré nos partenaires européens qui
commencent à râler de voir que la france
tire sur la planche à billets en
permanence et qu' elle ne fait aucune
aucun effort donc vous avez vous avez
les pays dits frugaux si vous voulez
qu'ils commencent à râler et je pense
que cette déclaration de bruno le maire
était plutôt orientée vers ces gens là
plutôt que
une réelle volonté
de couper les vivres puisque je vous dis
ils savent très bien que alors hein je
lui rappelle que l'économie française
est loin de tourner à 99 % des capacités
ça c'est un chiffre sait pas où il l'a
trouvé mais
je compte sur lui de toute façon pour ne
pas savoir compter donc c'est une fois
de plus mais malheureusement si vous
voulez hein qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça olivier que la passion nature on a
très bien vu qu'il y avait des dvd
utilisation de capacité par exemple dans
l'industrie ils sont loin d'être à 99%
donc soyons sérieux je sais pas où il a
sorti ce chiffre du chapeau mais ça ne
correspond pour moi pas grand chose et
secundo là vous avez donc une activité
qui est en réalité très faible vous avez
vu les chiffres de juillet avant le pass
sanitaires et je ne pense pas que le
pass and iter est arrangé les choses au
contraire donc le chiffre de juillet
vous êtes à -2 2% sur la consommation
donc il va pas me faire croire que tout
tourne à fond donc
je vous dis je pense que il a il a
envoyé un signal pour éviter que
certains s'énervent et puis il va faire
du ciblées qui sera très peu ciblé mais
plutôt de l'arrosage
et continuer jusqu'aux élections parce
qu'il sait très bien le jeu il arrête
c'est fini c'est les chaises musicales
si vous voulez y aura pas assez de
chaises pour tout le monde donc vous
aurez à ce moment là des chômeurs qui
vont arriver et vous aurez des sociétés
qui feront faillite à ce qu'on leur
demandera de rembourser quelque chose
qu'elles ne peuvent pas rembourser elle
en était bien incapable déjà avant de
s'endetter et aujourd'hui avec un
endettement qui est majeure elles ne
pourront pas parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'elle récupère non seulement leur
chiffre d'affaires avant d'avant mais
bien plus et qu'elles sont beaucoup plus
rentable donc ça ne se fera pas donc
vous aurez des chutes en
cascade et malheureusement
donc vous aurez un bruno le maire qui
reviendra sur ses déclarations dans
quelque temps d'en douter pas on va
marquer un courte pause et on vient dans
un instant
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez sommaire cette semaine la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte et pour en parler
nous sommes en liaison avec nicolas
dufresne directeur de l'institut
rousseau est nicolas dufresne grâce aux
quoi qu'il en coûte les défaillances
d'entreprises ont atteint un niveau
historiquement bas autour de 28000 sur
un nom selon la banque de france bruno
le maire a de son côté affiché un
optimisme le 30 août avec un objectif on
l'a dit de croissance fixé à 6% ça
signifie tout de même que ce quoi qu'il
en coûte il a été efficace
oui alors oui oui en effet il a permis
de mettre sous cloche si vous voulez une
partie de l'économie française et là je
rejoins olivier delamarche sur deux
poids premièrement c'est au moment où
ces mesures vont s'arrêter qu'on va voir
en effet que la dette privée est très
très importante et la tête des
entreprises est extrêmement importante
et qu'une partie d'entre elles ne
pourront pas survivre à cette période là
et d'autre part en effet on est très
loin de hong hong et on tourne plutôt
avec un taux d'utilisation des capacités
productives en france qui est entre 80
et 85% donc on est loin d'être d'être au
maximum mais si vous voulez c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'il est très important
d'anticiper dès maintenant cette sortie
crise et de et de trouver dès maintenant
les grands plans de relance qui
permettront d'engager l'économie sur
nous sur un nouveau dynamisme et c'est
ça qu'on ne peut pas faire si on
s'obstine dans une politique d'austérité
dans une politique de rigueur qui
conduit à baisser les dépenses publiques
à ne pas financer l'innovation les
infrastructures la reconstruction
écologique par exemple qu'on sait c'est
pas le cas relanceur
mais écoutez france relance pour
l'instant c'est très faible notre plan
d'investissement c30 c'est censé être
100 milliards d'euros mais c'est sur
plusieurs années donc sur 2021 vous
n'avez vu que 30 milliards d'euros
d'investissements supplémentaires dont
une grande partie sur des baisses de
charge ce n'est pas avec ça qu'on crée
véritablement un plan de relance c'est
aux états unis on rappelle que le
troisième uniquement le troisième plan
de relance mis en place par joe biden
s'est déjà de mille milliards de dollars
donc si vous voulez on en est vraiment
très très loin
l'essentiel du plan de relance européen
c'est aussi des prêts qu'il faudra
rembourser et donc on se retrouve dans
une situation où avec des dettes
publiques très importante d'un côté et
des dettes privées encore plus
importante de l'autre côté on se
retrouve dans une situation où on risque
un petit peu l'asphyxient en sortie de
crise et donc le la chute drastique de
l'investissement c'est pour ça que je
pense ma conviction est que l'état a un
rôle encore beaucoup plus important à
jouer pour prendre le relais notamment
des politiques monétaires et que si on
craint l'endettement elle va alors faut
recourir si on veut donner des gages à
d'autres pays européens il faut recourir
à des solutions un petit peu originales
comme celles qu'on avait défendu qui
était avec l'institut rousseau et avec
un gaël giraud notamment comme
l'annulation des dettes publiques
détenues par la banque centrale
européenne qui ne lui servent
strictement à rien et parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui 25% de notre dette
publique est détenue par la banque
centrale européenne ce qui ne lui sert
strictement à rien donc si on annulait
cette dette en échange d'investissements
dans la reconstruction du pays et de
l'europe on aurait certainement là des
marges de manoeuvre importantes pour
faire face justement
cette sous utilisation de nos capacités
productives et à ce risque de faillite
importants qui se profile alors on l'a
dit en place désormais à du sur mesure
le fonds de solidarité va donc être
prolongé jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre avec comme en août une
indemnisation à hauteur de 20% du
chiffre d'affaires
à partir du 1er octobre un nouveau
dispositif prendra le relais en
dispositif de prise en charge des coûts
fixes qui permettra je cite une
indemnisation ciblée sur les entreprises
qui enregistrent réellement est des
pertes olivier votre regard sur ce
nouveau à dispositif sachant qu'on a
souvent reproché justement au quoi qu'il
en coûte le fait que les aides n'étaient
pas assez a ciblé et vous l'avez vous
l'avait redit tout à l'heure est ce que
finalement ce sur mesure il n'est pas un
peu plus pertinents alors il aurait été
pertinent s'il avait été fait dès le
début donc aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
donc de fin de l'histoire si vous
laissez pas parce que vous faites
quelque chose
enfin deux en fin de 2 2
de la crise si encore on est en fin de
la crise ce qui ce qui pour l'instant vu
les mesures qui ont été prises semble
douteux mais
maintenant vous arrivez en faisant du
sur mesure le sur mesure fallait le
faire dès le départ il fallait faire
fallait cibler sur les entreprises qui
était viable mais qui ne keane qui avait
des difficultés ponctuelles parce qu'on
les ferme et on a on a arrêté l'activité
et donc on sait me l'a arrosé tout le
monde même les entreprises zombies qui
en ont largement profité
donc ça n'est pas une solution devenir
maintenant nous expliquer qui fait qu'il
faut faire du sur mesure c'était avant
comme toujours mais bon mais je voudrais
rebondir un tout petit peu sur ce que
monsieur dufresne a dit le l'effacement
des dettes moi c'est un truc qui me fait
marrer c'est c'est tellement facile
finalement 1 ont fait de la dette et
puis on les fasse à on l'a fait racheter
par la bce qui imprime des billets pour
le faire et ensuite on les fasse mais
pourquoi paye ton des impôts
finalement pourquoi paye ton des impôts
puisque c'est si facile
il est si facile d'imprimer il est si
facile d'acheter cette dette par la bce
pourquoi se limiter d'abord à 25%
pourquoi nash est t'elle pas toutes les
dettes de la zone un peu comme le japon
si vous voulez pourquoi ne l'achètent
elle n'achète elles pas toutes les
dettes de la zone euro
et pourquoi ne les fassent elles pas
puisque c'est facile allons jusqu'au
bout et puis surtout supprimons les
impôts complètement puisque il suffira
de d'imprimer pour faire le budget de
l'état donc je vois vraiment pas
pourquoi on se gêne et pourquoi on
s'embête depuis des années à faire payer
des impôts aux gens pour essayer de
rembourser une dette qui est
irremboursable puisque il suffit de la
passer au tipex c'est vraiment
merveilleux une réponse peut-être dé
quoi dufresne oui alors j'ai envie de
dire que vous me tenter avec votre
programme supprimons les impôts et
c'est bon de la monnaie non non a dit
allons-y et puis ça bien sûr a alors
allons tous aller à dans nos banques
respectives pour leur dire que
finalement on rembourse pas parce que ça
n'a aucune conséquence donc allons-y
gaiement plus plus sérieusement je pense
que là on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle si vous voulez pendant la
période du coc vide la dette publique de
la france a augmenté d'à peu près 500
600 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire à peu près 20% et c'est à
peu près le montant que détient la
banque centrale européenne il faut
savoir que depuis vingt ans le bilan des
banques centrales a été multipliée par
sept ou huit c'est à dire que le bilan
de la banque centrale européenne est
passée de 500 milliards d'euros a
aujourd'hui plus de 7000 milliards
d'euros cet argent ou et qu'il allait
essentiellement dans les marchés
financiers donc une question qu'on pose
c'est une question que j'ai posée
notamment dans un livre que j'ai coécrit
avec un alain grandjean et c'est de
savoir si cette création monétaire de la
banque centrale ne pourrait pas être
mieux fléché ne pourrait pas servir
justement à financer des investissements
bien ciblées et non pas à faire
alimenter si vous voulez les marchés
financiers en liquidités qu'on retrouve
soit dans les actions les dépassements
il faut quand même rappeler que les
marchés d'actions ont battu leur record
historique en pleine crise en pleine
crise économique ce qui est complètement
absurde donc est ce que cette création
monétaire ne pourrait pas mieux la
fléche et sur des investissements
utilisé en effet la manne la planche à
billets n'est pour des investissements
bien ciblés qu'ils soient producteurs de
richesses culture et qui ne soit pas
producteur d'inflation mais je rappelle
quand même que la seule conséquence
d'utiliser plus largement le pouvoir de
création monétaire ça pourrait davantage
d'inflation or aujourd'hui on aimerait
bien avoir un peu plus d'inflation parce
que ça nous permettrait d'avoir une
hausse des salaires et cette hausse des
salaires nous permettrait de digérer
plus facilement les dettes nous avons
accumulé voilà donc je pense que
1 des jeux juge je termine sur ce point
mais je pense bien des grands de la
reprise c'est vraiment d'avoir une
hausse des salaires publics et privés et
un petit peu d'inflation pour qu'on
puisse digérer cette dette qui s'est
accumulée sinon on va étouffer
merci merci pour tout une question juste
raté l'enlever quand avez vous vu un
investissement intelligent fait par
l'état
écoutez par exemple les administrations
ont récemment demandé à l'êta de rénover
leurs bâtiments pour faire de la
rénovation énergétique et du coup
économiser en factures de chauffage et
bien sûr diminuer les émissions de co2
ils ont présenté un plan pour neuf
milliards d'euros et l'état ne va leur
donner que deux milliards d'euros donc
déjà là on aurait 7 milliards d'euros
d'investissements intelligente à faire
qui nous aiderait qui feraient
travailler des petites entreprises
locales parce que ça ne se délocalisent
pas qui
nous permettrait de baisser nos
émissions et de tenir notre place pour
les accords de paris donc ça par exemple
ça pourrait être un investissement
intelligent on en aurait pourri mozart
le fait oui mais ça n'est pas fait
et voilà merci beaucoup olivier merci
merci nicolas dufresne d'avoir été parmi
nous je rappelle que vous êtes est
directeur de l'institut rousseau et puis
nous en livier on continue chez avec la
troisième partie merci
et on commence tout de suite avec le
commentaire de vannes célestes et
comment fait-on pour sortir de ce
système où la dette et sa gestion
dépassent l'économie réelle car à un
moment la question du remboursement se
pose
eh bien vous avez tout à fait raison à
un moment
ça se pose comme question alors certains
vont vous dire
que il suffit d'effacer la dette je suis
pas certain que ça fonctionne comme ça
et le problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas
arrêter mais on vous le dit depuis
longtemps la les banques centrales se
sont engagés et les gouvernements aussi
se sont engagés dans quelque chose sur
lequel il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
possible
donc maintenant vous avez deux solutions
soit défaut sur la dette
c'est sale ça fait très mal soit
inflation enfin
hyperinflation qui en fait la la
dévaluation de la monnaie qui fait que
votre monnaie ne vaut plus rien et à ce
moment là votre dette non plus donc
voilà c'est les deux solutions c'est pas
des solutions soient scellées deux
conséquences de ce que de ce à quoi on
joue depuis maintenant une douzaine
d'années merci beaucoup olivier c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant à découvrez nos
précédentes émissions sur notre site
internet à l'adresse rt france point tv
olivier c'est à vous pour le mot de la
fin à la dette c'est comme la drogue on
n'arrête pas comme ça